The Halloween franchise has had so many twists
and turns that trying to sort out the story
can be a little confusing.
No worries, though.
We've laid out the whole timeline in detail.
From that first night of terror to Michael's
bloody return, here's the entire Halloween
story finally explained.
Halloween opens on Halloween night in 1963.
Judith Myers should be babysitting her six-year-old
brother, Michael, but what she's actually
doing is making out with her boyfriend.
So Michael decides he's going to spend his
evening doing some killing.
After slaughtering his sister, he's institutionalized,
and his psychiatrist, Dr. Sam Loomis, becomes
convinced that Michael is pure evil and should
never be allowed back into the world.
"I told everybody!
Nobody listened!"
But, in 1978, Michael escapes and heads back
to his hometown, looking to pick up right
where he left off.
When he gets home, he finds high schooler
Laurie Strode hanging around, so of course
he decides to make her and her friends his
next targets.
For the rest of the night, Michael stalks
and kills Laurie's friends, one by one.
But Laurie is stronger than he gives her credit
for, and she manages to fend him off long
enough to allow Loomis to arrive on the scene
and shoot him six times, knocking him off
a balcony and onto the ground below.
That same night, Laurie is taken to Haddonfield
Memorial Hospital.
Michael survives his fall from the balcony,
and follows Laurie because he's not one to
let his victims get away.
It's also discovered that Laurie is, surprise!
Michael's younger sister.
"That girl, that Strode girl.
That's Michael Myers' sister."
And Michael is, even bigger surprise! possibly
being kept alive because of a Samhain curse.
Michael wanders through the hospital in search
of Laurie, killing anyone and everyone that
gets in his way, while Loomis starts his inevitable
descent into madness, trying to convince anyone
within earshot of Michael's evil immortality.
In a final confrontation, Michael stabs Loomis
in the stomach, but not before Loomis sets
the hospital up to explode.
Laurie gets out in time, but Michael and Loomis
are trapped inside when the building goes
up in flames.
Michael Myers takes a backseat in Halloween
3, which takes place a few days prior to the
holiday.
When a man is killed in a northern California
hospital by a group of mysterious, well-dressed
men, Dan Challis,the doctor in charge of his
care, takes it upon himself to try and solve
the case.
He traces the crime all the way back to Silver
Shamrock Novelties and a man named Conal Cochran,
who's somehow managed to steal a piece of
Stonehenge.
He plans to use it as part of a sacrifice
involving children and a trio of Halloween
masks, with the goal of reclaiming the Samhain
holiday for witches.
But Dan thwarts Cochran's plan, for the most
part.
There are robots, killer bugs, and the possibility
of a whole lot of child death, but no Michael
Myers.
A decade after the hospital explosion, Michael
awakens from a coma, just in time to hunt
his niece, Jamie, on Halloween.
Jamie, as it happens, is the seven-year-old
daughter of Laurie, who died in a car accident.
Jamie's currently living with another family,
but her true lineage isn't a secret, so she's
bullied pretty heavily.
"I don't need to wear a stupid costume."
"That's because everyday is Halloween in Jamie's
house.
Right, Jamie?
'Cause your uncle is the Boogeyman."
Halloween 4 is a pretty straightforward slasher
flick, in that the bulk of it consists of
Michael Myers killing a bunch of poorly developed
characters in the most ridiculous ways imaginable.
But eventually, Loomis returns, because he's
somehow also managed to survive that hospital
explosion, and he helps Jamie defeat her uncle
with the help of a town lynch mob.
Sadly, it seems as though psychopathy runs
in the family, because after Michael falls
through a mine shaft, Jamie tries to kill
her foster mother with a pair of scissors.
Michael, wounded from the attempt on his life
in Halloween 4, crawls into a cave and immediately
passes out.
He wakes up on Halloween Eve a year later,
in the care of another cave dweller.
Michael kills him and sets course for his
niece, who's been living as a mute at the
Haddonfield Children's Clinic for the last
year.
It's clear Jamie and Michael are connected
on a deeper level than just blood.
The two are psychically paired, so everything
Michael does from here on out, Jamie sees.
After his killing spree, Jamie tries to appeal
to his emotions, but Michael isn't interested
in anything other than killing.
"In my heart, I knew that Hell would not have
him."
Loomis swoops in, but winds up suffering a
stroke.
There's no hero here, just a random set of
circumstances that leads to Michael's arrest.
In the end, a strange Man in Black who's been
following Michael this entire time comes to
the police station to retrieve him.
Six years later, we learn that the Man in
Black is the leader of a Druid cult that's
connected to Michael on account of a mark
he has on the inside of his wrist.
Turns out, it's related to the so-called "curse
of Thorn," the thing responsible for both
Michael's immortality and his insatiable desire
to kill his family.
"Michael's work isn't done in Haddonfield.
And soon, very soon, he'll come home."
Jamie, now 14, has delivered a baby in the
captivity of the cult.
Immediately after giving birth, she tries
to escape the cult's clutches and outrun her
uncle.
She fails, and Michael kills her in a barn.
The rest of the film shifts focus to Tommy
Doyle, the now adult boy that Laurie Strode
used to babysit.
He's obsessed with the curse of Thorn, and
with the old Myers home in general.
Eventually, thanks to his help, Loomis is
able to take Michael down.
Or is he?
Laurie Strode makes her return to the franchise
with Halloween H20: 20 Years Later, a film
that gets back to basics, effectively wiping
out everything that's happened after Halloween
II.
Michael Myers is still family, but Laurie
is alive, having faked her death, and she's
working as the headmistress of her son John's
private boarding school in California.
Michael reappears 20 years after that hospital
explosion and manages to track Laurie down
by way of an old file one of Loomis' colleagues
had on hand.
In spite of her overprotective nature, Laurie
can't protect John and his friends from Michael's
wrath, and on Halloween night, the masked
killer stalks and kills pretty much everyone
at the school before Laurie can subdue him.
"He's dead.
He's dead."
Laurie doesn't stop there, though.
She hijacks the coroner's van with Michael's
body, sends the slasher through the windshield,
pins him to a fence, and then takes an ax
to his head.
All these years later, Laurie has finally
gotten her revenge, except for one tiny detail.
The man Laurie decapitated wasn't actually
Michael.
It was a paramedic with a crushed larynx that
Michael had tricked her into thinking was
him.
Three years later, Laurie has convinced the
staff at Grace Andersen Sanitarium that she's
basically comatose while she waits for a final,
final showdown with her brother.
Things don't go as planned, and Laurie winds
up with a knife in her back before she plummets
off the hospital roof.
"I'll see you in Hell."
The focus then turns to the old Myers house,
where a group of college kids have agreed
to star in an investigative web series.
Michael follows the group into the house and
proceeds to kill each hopeful internet star,
all in front of a live audience who assumes
for a good part of the night that everything
happening is fake.
When the Myers house is accidentally set ablaze,
Michael is trapped inside and supposedly dies.
You may have thought Laurie Strode was out
for good, but 2018's Halloween made the decision
to retcon everything after the 1978 original,
which means that this time, there's no sibling
drama.
"Wasn't it her brother, who like cold-blooded
murdilated all those teenagers?"
"No.
That's just a bit that some people made up
to make them feel better I think."
And, most importantly, Laurie is very much
alive, although she's spent four decades living
like the slasher movie equivalent of a Doomsday
prepper.
Michael has been locked up at Smith's Grove
Sanitarium, but after a pair of investigative
reporters come to interview him, he decides
40 years is long enough behind bars and sets
out for a final face-off with the babysitter
that got away.
Laurie, on the other hand, has a strained
relationship with her daughter Karen, but
her granddaughter Allyson wants to mend fences.
Everything changes when Michael returns, and
Laurie, Karen, and Allyson team up to take
him down.
It's discovered that Michael's psychiatrist,
Dr. Sartain, is obsessed with him and was
the one behind his escape.
Eventually, the Strode clan defeats Michael
with the power of fire and firearms.
"Gotcha."
But as we all know, there's probably no stopping
this psycho slasher.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.